[Music]
it's time for et's late-night roundup
your quick catch up on all the best
celebrity scoop after dark who do you
love more the Patriots are Tom Brady
uh that's tough that's it's a tough
thing lots of sports talk on evening TV
Monday on Jimmy Kimmel Live Chris Evan
got candid about his obsession with his
hometown NFL team the New England
Patriots specifically quarterback Tom
Brady
I love the Patriots like I like any
sports entity but but Tom is a suspect
the gifted star was in the crowd when
the Patriots won the Super Bowl
earlier this year but still their paths
never crossed I didn't meet Tom and I'm
not sure if I want it like it almost
it's become now like I just want to let
him be the thing that I imagine he is
yeah and that's it that's good enough
next over on The Late Late Show James
Corden celebrated the NCAA men's
championship by remixes to the ball to
the straight jump down Chris Paul oh
he's so tall and there was plenty more
music on The Tonight Show where host
Jimmy Fallon had a lip-sync battle with
Shaquille O'Neal and surprise guest
pitbull
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
you